[Musique]
au plus près des oeuvres du Roi Soleil 9
peintures issues de la collection
personnelle de Louis XIV sont présentés
au château de Versailles dans
l'exposition chef-d'oeuvre de la chambre
du roi provenant de ce lieu central de
la demeure du monarque ces portraits ont
dû être décrochés suite aux travaux en
cours dans l'appartement royal des
tableaux qui ornent à la fois les deux
supports ce sont les ovales que nous
voyons ici et dans la partie haute de la
chambre en attique six tableaux 6
tableaux qui proviennent de ces
collections
qu'il a acheté dans les années
760 770 des oeuvres inspirés de
l'artiste Caravage mettant en scène peu
de personnages et bouleversant les codes
de la peinture à l'époque une esthétique
sobre et purée contrastant avec
l'ornementation de la chambre du roi et
certainement
il admirait
ses tableaux ces tableaux qui ont tous
un sujet religieux la religion va en
prendre de plus en plus de place
dans son quotidien et ces tableaux
avaient certainement pour lui une
puissance d'évocation lors de la
création de sa chambre Louis XIV décide
de donner à l'artiste peintre Valentin
de Boulogne une place dominante un des
grands noms du XVIIe siècle au style
empreint de gravité et de mélancolie ce
qui est merveilleux dans ce dans ce
tableau c'est les contrastes et les jeux
de texture je dirais entre l'aile qui
est l'aile d'un
oiseau et au contraire les physiques
burinés du sein
habituellement accroché à 6 mètres de
hauteur il est possible d'admirer de
près ces portraits pour la première fois
depuis la fin du XVIIe siècle
l'exposition chèvre de la chambre du roi
se tiendra au château de Versailles
jusqu'au 16 juillet 2023